how cool is this I'm Kristian harloff
I'm here with Rob Kazinsky star of
Warcraft it's or Goering himself who's
gonna teach me how to fight like an orc
to it I'm gonna try you get a job yes
you know as well as I do I'm gonna film
is we're gonna try well I'm not mr.
Miyagi you know there's no there's no
quick way through this first of all it
has now become widely known how much of
a warpath yeah oh yeah pretty much how
many years I've been playing for 10
years there were there abouts there was
a period of time when it was 18 hours a
day and I did I did 18 hours a day for
18 months it was an incredibly important
part of my life which is why it's such a
privilege for me to be a part of the
film okay
I'm here to try to find out how to fight
like an orc right all right the first
thing about being an orc
alright is you aren't light footed so
all this stopping this step doesn't work
just plant it nice and wide second off
your 700 pounds of muscle you're not
gonna be any tip toes all right you're
gonna drop your weight into your belly
all right bend your knees a little bit
silly you're heavy
you got a stuff from this kind of place
of if you push me I'm not moving like
see look at solid base alright so it
becomes about moving like an orc
which is not human there's no quick
turns there's no head snaps if you want
to turn the head goes first and then the
body follows and you just rock solid so
then when you take a weapon like this
there's no thrust and parry or anything
there's no quick movements it's push or
slice and then yeah brute force big
movements and big pushes and just all
strength stuff right hold this for
example holding this down with strokes
see okay so much you want to grab this
hand here because that's the South
angrier you're sweeping it like a scythe
that's it and then you would bury it in
my face or something going straight in
I'm going yeah go on
yeah you will just like step with your
left foot just jab alright and then even
one up like that if I watch you cut me
by the way you could but I mean what
would be better if you slam it there
yeah and then you take it around your
head
ah so you really still you don't give
him a chance don't give me a chance oh
and then look where my head is see done
right teaching your audience how to
decapitate individuals responsible
television dango family friendly
you